Our next case comes from the Supreme Court of Minnesota in 1957 and deals with
the role of advertising and forming the contract.
On Friday,
April 6th,
1956 the Great Minneapolis surplus store published an advertisement in the
newspaper,
very much like the one you see here.
It advertised Saturday 9:00 AM sharp,
three brand new fur coats worth to $1,000 first come first served $1 each.
Then the very next day Morris Lefkowitz went to the store,
was the first to present himself at the appropriate counter,
asked for the coat and indicated his readiness to pay the sales price of $1 but
the store refused to sell it to him.
Telling him that they had a house rule that the advertised offer applied only to
women.
The following week on Friday the 13th the Great Minneapolis surplus store again
placed an ad in the newspaper.
This time advertising scarves and stoles in particular at advertised one black
Lapin stole beautiful worth $139 and 50 cents $1 first come first served.
Mr Luftwitz again went to the store again was the first to ask for the stole,
but they once again told him that they would not sell it to him and that he
already knew the house rule.
Lefkowitz then proceeded to sue the store for the value of the firs they refuse
to sell him.
The court in this case face the question of whether there was a contract at all.
Lefkowitz argued that the advertisements constituted offers which he had then
accepted by showing up at the Great Minneapolis surplus store at the appointed
time and ready to pay a dollar.
The store on the other hand argued that the ads were just invitations for an
offer,
uh,
and not offers themselves the store.
His argument is equivalent to saying that the ads were soliciting offers from
prospective customers.
Justice Murphy had to decide whether the advertisements in this case we're
offers that become binding contracts when Lefkowitz excepted them.
There are three different ways we can view advertisements.
First,
they could be,
as Lefkowitz argues,
simply offers.
Once they are accepted,
they become binding contracts.
Second,
they might instead be just notices that the seller plans to make offers at a
particular time and place in the future or third,
they might be solicitations notices that the seller would like to receive offers
from.
Interested buyers in general.
Advertisements nowadays are usually interpreted belonged to categories two and
three.
Category One is rather exceptional.
The court lays out a rule for when advertisements constitute an offer saying
that where the offer is clear,
definite and explicit and leaves nothing open for negotiation,
it constitutes an offer acceptance of which will complete the contract.
That is if an ad specifies the exact exchange,
the terms that will take place and exactly what the buyer must do in order to
take advantage of it.
The ad is an offer and the buyer can enforce once he or she has accepted it.
Take note of something odd about this rule.
It seems to be intended to encourage definite contracting,
uh,
presumably to protect consumers from an,
from unscrupulous businesses.
But what would you do if you owned a store and you read this opinion?
You would make sure that all advertisements in the future,
we're indefinite enough that no one could enforce them against you in court.
Justice Murphy goes on to apply the rule to the two advertisements that
Lefkowitz saw.
He finds that the first advertisement for the coat was not an offer worth to
$100 was not sufficiently definite good.
A coat been worth 50 or $60 be relevant would it have to be exactly $100 but the
second advertisement,
which exactly specified the value of the stall,
uh,
was definite enough.
And so Lefkowitz was able to receive expectation damages.
The $139 and 50 cent value of the stool minus the $1 he would had to pay for it.
Notice that Murphy's rule has a perverse likely consequence.
The reluctance of courts to enforce indefinite contracts seems to be intended to
encourage both parties to take more care to resolve ambiguities in there
drafting language.
But Justice Murphy's being unwilling to give legal effects to indefinite offers
might have the opposite effect.
What would you do if you owned a store the week after you read this opinion?
What kind of an ad would you place the next week?
Well,
you might make sure that all advertisements you issued from here on out,
we're indefinite enough by saying things like worth two x dollars so that no one
could enforce them against you in court.
As for the house rule,
Justice Murphy deals with it quite quickly.
The restriction was not part of the original offer and quote.
While an advertiser has the right at any time before acceptance to modify his
offer,
he does not have the right after acceptance to impose new or arbitrary
conditions.
Since the restriction to women wasn't part of the original newspaper Ad,
the store couldn't add it as an extra condition after Lefkowitz had successfully
accepted the offer.
Notice again how crucial timing is in this case,
if the store manager had called out,
we revoke the offer before I left,
Jeff Lefkowitz said anything or if a large sign on the outside of the store said
we revoke our code offer,
then Lefkowitz might have lost.
Even with regard to the second ad.
Yeah.
The court doesn't seem to care that Lefkowitz already knew about the house rule
when he came to the store the second time.
So with regard to the house rule,
there is a stronger case for not allowing Lefkowitz to accept the second offer.
Perhaps the court thought the store was engaging in deceptive bait and switch
marketing tactics and wanting to find a way to penalize the score store,
believe it or not,
gender discrimination and contracting is actually legal in every state except
California.
Unlike race discrimination and contracting,
which is prohibited under federal law,
federal law prohibits gender discrimination in contract late in contracting only
in a handful of specific markets such as employment and housing.
California's Unruh Civil Rights Act does band gender discrimination in
contracting along with dim miss discrimination on the basis of wide range of
other characteristics.
Several states have now also prohibited sex discrimination with regard to public
accommodations,
which increasingly encompasses a wide range of retail sales.
Okay.
Which of the following ads would,
would justice Murphy be most likely to consider an offer?
Option d is the one that is most likely to be an offer because it specifies the
exact value of the products on offer,
as well as how a buyer can accept by being among the first customers to arrive
on the specify day.
From this case.
We have seen that advertisements are typically treated as solicitations for
customers to make offers rather than as offers themselves.
But some courts do treat advertisements as offers when they are clear,
definite and explicit,
and leave nothing open for negotiation.
And the court's view,
the Great Minneapolis surplus stores,
second advertisement met these requirements.
Okay.